ich bin süchtig nach diesem Sommerrollen
und sie sind das perfekte Essen für das
schöne warme Wetter dafür schneide ich
einfach Gemüse in feine Streifen koche
kurz die Glasnudeln und brate das
Hähnchen an die Gewürze und alle
weiteren Zutaten schreibe ich euch
natürlich ganz genau auf die Reisblätter
werden nur für 3 Sekunden in kaltes
Wasser getunkt danach werden sie auf der
Arbeitsfläche sowieso noch mal ein
bisschen weicher befüllt sie dann aber
nicht zu voll weil sonst nicht zu
bekommen und dann das Ganze einmal
verschließen und so weitermachen bis sie
komplett alles aufgebraucht habt für die
blitzschnelle erdnuss-soße knoblauch und
Ingwer anderes und das ganze mit
Kokosmilch ablöschen dann gibt ihr
Zucker Sojasoße und Erdnussbutter dazu
und fertig ist der perfekte Dip für eure
leckeren Sommerrollen